[Music]
in ukraine the price of food jumped 55
percent vegetables are 32 percent more
expensive
and on these shelves salt cost up to
three times more than just a few months
ago
i am at the supermarket in western part
of ukraine where we can see how the war
has affected daily lives of ukrainians
beyond deadly fighting and destruction
in supermarkets now it's hard to afford
even
basics
the war in ukraine has pushed up prices
around the world but inside the country
inflation is much higher than global
figures
people have been taken to social media
to post memes comparing salt to luxury
goods such as diamonds
it's a big deal because people need salt
right now to put away non-perishable
food for the winter
here's how the bar is driving inflation
and raising fears of food shortages
ukraine is a major global food producer
before the war the country was
responsible for nearly 12 percent of the
world's wheat supply
and almost 50 of sunflower oil experts
ukraine is also home to one of europe's
largest salt factories which exported
salt to neighboring countries like
romania moldova and georgia
and just like for grain and sunflower
oil the water has disrupted salt
supplies
this factory was damaged by shelling in
the region and was forced to shot
according to a spokesman who told us
operations wouldn't restart until the
war is over
so in supermarkets people are likely to
continue to find a lot of imported salt
which is much more expensive
that's hitting some ukrainians
particularly hard
with incomes dropping prices of food
going up and uncertainty over supplies
many here use salt to pickle lots of
vegetables and stock up on food that can
help them survive the winter
like most ukrainians lida has been
pickling vegetables for years she grows
them herself in her garden but since
harvest season is different
she's afraid of famine and wants to
stockpile food
[Music]
the country is still producing some salt
ukraine's other salt mine is in troho
beach in the west of the country where
fighting's been limited so far the
johorsh salt work which virtually
remains the only salt producer in
ukraine now is operating at full
capacity but we can't film there because
it's forbidden to film infrastructural
objects while the war is not over
in the near future the plan plans to
increase production but this won't be
able to meet the demand of even a
quarter of the country
officials have said there won't be a
salt deficit and that prices are stable
but that doesn't mean food is or will
remain affordable
as the war grinds on the economy is
expected to shrink by almost half this
year and contribute to keeping the cost
of basics high
[Music]